a lot of strange things happen in 2022
today I'm going to share with you
lessons we can learn from 2022 so we
don't repeat many of these mistakes in
2023.
[Music]
all right so let's get right into it I
have a lot of different points the first
one I'm going to talk about is the
following one don't believe your own
hype here's what I mean by it a lot of
people made a lot of money in 2021 going
into 2022 so these folks in real estate
were making 50 100 200 300 Grand a month
the crypto people were making money
there was a bunch of crypto millionaires
nft millionaires all of this stuff and
they started believing that maybe I am
better than I really am maybe I'm really
smarter than everybody else and then the
bad economy shows up the way you and I
can judge ourselves if we should even
believe the hype is when you win during
a great Market but also when you win
during a bad Market 2022 filtered out a
lot of people who only won during the
Great Market listen the second one I
don't even know why we do this but we
all fall for it don't buy into polls
polls tell you a bunch of different
things let me tell you it's going to be
a big red wave Republicans are going to
do this and there's no Blue Wave you
know this person is going to win that
person is going to win we have put way
too much trust in polls it's time to
only give this much credibility to post
and see what happens because events
people things we say things politicians
say it's so volatile right now that
anything can change at any time no
matter how much credibility a poll has
had for 10 20 30 40 50 years all right
third one a lot of people became experts
at zooms oh my God I love to do Zoom so
hey would you like to uh talk to a
little bit more about our business and
what we're doing yes let's do it on Zoom
let's do it on Zoom let's do it on Zoom
so people got lazier and lazier and
lazier and lazier and lazier and then
they realize Zoom work during covid and
zoom is a good tool to use all the time
but Zoom doesn't build culture you saw
Zoom stock drop the same way Zoom went
up like this is the same way zooming
down like this when people realize there
is power in the handshake there is power
in this I told the story the other day
to one of our guys that's 28 years old
who was sitting there saying I'm going
to be doing Zoom for the rest of my life
and it was single I said listen let me
explain to you zoom versus face to face
I said uh you go on dates for girls he
says yes I said I want you about if you
go on a date with a girl on Zoom no
matter how good of a job you do spit and
Gain No matter how good of a job you say
saying anything to them you know ain't
nothing happening tonight I said but if
you go on dinner with a girl same girl
and you're at dinner you're going to
bring your game why because if you spit
good game good things may happen to you
right Zoom was good temporarily for
covet and it's good to use on subtle
different things if you're dealing with
people internationally but nothing beats
face to face to build culture no matter
what industry or business we're talking
about so two stories I want to share
with you crazy just last week an email
goes out to a bunch of our employees
from me apparently asking for their
phone number so a bunch of our employees
send the email back saying hey Pat
here's my number how to get a hold of me
then a number text them for credit card
one of our employees ends up responding
back with the credit card she lost 400
because they thought it was me why would
ask for 400 but that's what happened to
one of our employees another story is
when a guy sends me messages on WhatsApp
saying hey Pat just so you know your
past word your information is on the
dark group I said what so finally we
decided to partner with a new partner
sponsor we're very excited about Aura
what Aura does for a living is protect
against any of that stuff happening to
you let me tell you how so Aura protects
you from scammers and hackers by
scanning the so-called dark web where
criminals sell stolen information
looking for your email's password and
Social Security numbers and what Aura
does is it alerts you fast if it finds
anything they also can help fight back
against those annoying websites that
make your personal information public
for automatically requesting removal of
your info this helps reduce those Robo
calls they'll protect against any kind
of suspicious credit inquires boom
you'll get alerted by them they protect
devices from viruses malware spyware I
mean I can go on and on talking to you
about what they're doing against kids
when your kids have four kids when they
use phones what they can have access to
the the password all of that stuff Aura
does in one place some of you may be
having certain companies that do one or
two of these things but Aura does all of
that in one place having said that or do
the hard work of keeping you safe online
if you sign up right now with aura they
will give you a two-week free trial with
my link go to aura.com forward slash pbd
once again aura.com forward slash pbd to
start your free trial also link below in
the description this one's very
interesting a lot of people try to bully
Employers in 2022 and it backfired Q3 of
2022 why in 2021 everybody was
recruiting sixty thousand dollar salary
hey this other person's willing to pay
me 80 if you don't pay me I'm leaving
today with a ten thousand dollar bonus
oh my god let's pay him the bonus Boom
the next the next the next the next they
did that once twice three times until
people realize during covert you had two
three jobs you kept doing all this other
stuff now everyone knows a lot of things
about you so now a lot of people are
going to have resumes with gaps where
they're gonna say well during this nine
month period I was helping my mother
because she was sick I was helping my
father because he wasn't doing too well
no you abuse an employer and you know
they're not going to say good things
about you so on your resume there's
going to be a gap now if you didn't do
this you're like Pat what are you
talking about I didn't do that there are
a lot of people that did do that and
employers are starting to realize that
that was gamesmanship and just so you
know that doesn't help a lot with
credibility for those who do that now
those employees who during covid stayed
true to the company and they brought
value and they grew the company they
have the most leverage today because
they showed loyalty and the company
knows hey man we value that's the
leverage the employees got who became
entrepreneurs and leaders for the
company during covet while everybody was
running around sleeping around with a
bunch of different employers credit to
those that stuck on with the right
companies that had the right opportunity
for them five bad policies and ideas
have consequences what do I mean by this
politically we have consequences let's
print money send money to everybody
people got rich next thing you know oh
my gosh this money is gone what do we do
now hey Disney we're gonna go do this
with cartoons and movies great idea no
it's not the audience didn't like it hey
Netflix here's what we're gonna do no
the audience they don't like it that's a
bad idea hey all of these people that
have bad policies or bad ideas the
market said to them we don't like your
ideas and policies bam they took a big
hit so it's very easy next time you're
thinking about coming up with a policy
or an idea process it with other people
not just with people you agree with
specifically with people that also
disagree with you to see that you may
have a blind spot that you're not seeing
don't ever give two billion dollars to
somebody without an exchange for any
board seats and what I'm talking about
is SBF this guy's Sam bankman freed is
the next you know Warren Buffett of the
new era which is a bunch of different
guys we're talking about I took two
billion dollars he manipulated the
marketplace made a bunch of money stole
a bunch of money pure Criminal on what
he did and a lot of it's not coming out
that a lot of people from both sides are
noticing what he did and in exchange all
these big companies like BlackRock
Insight race two billion dollars never
ask for a board seat those ideas are
playing that Reckless us and aggressive
with investors money showed in 2022 you
cannot pick your winners too early they
got to prove themselves but again this
is going to happen again and again again
except in 2023 you're going to see a lot
of these money people actually pay
attention to the right data that matters
instead of just winging it the way they
did in 2020 2021 and early 2022. the
business model of a bully is a short
life span you can't bully for too long
let me explain to what I mean by this
social media was bullying a lot of
people canceling you know censoring all
this other stuff oh we're not censoring
anybody oh we're not doing any of this
stuff a guy named Elon Musk comes and
buys Twitter Twitter files comes out all
of these people got exposed because
bullion doesn't work fauci here's what
you got to do you got to take that you
got to take this you got to do this or
else or else or else or else or else now
those files are coming up bullying work
for a couple years but it's not a
business model long term not in politics
not in business not in church not in
anything eventually Bullies Are Gonna
face the one thing they feel you the
most and that's the truth and a True
Believer a leader who doesn't fear their
[ __ ] and that's happening right now
in 2022 and this by the way will
continue into 2023. we learned in 2022
just because somebody calls somebody a
journalist doesn't mean they're actually
doing the job of a journalist and we
realize we're starting to believe
citizen journalism more than actual
traditional mainstream media journalism
which is kind of weird citizen
journalism people are listening to
podcasters what kind of weird thing
that's taking place but that's becoming
more and more and more you're going to
start hearing about these journalists
working at mainstream Medias are
frightened of Citizen journalism because
God forbid if their business model
doesn't work and they have to go start
their own podcast without the massive
engine behind them they may get exposed
realizing how hard it actually is to run
a podcast and a show without a
teleprompter right in front of them
they're just they're just reading what a
producer or somebody wrote for them it's
a very interesting thing we learned in
2022 this is another one of those things
that I think is going to go go and show
up again 2023 24 25. the world
population ain't slowing down even
though we're not having as many babies
as we typically were having before we
just crossed 8 billion people and even
though we have 8 billion people the
world is smaller than it's ever been
before because we're 40 years ago when
something happened in Taiwan or Korea or
Russia or the Middle East it would take
a minute until we felt the residual
effects of it here for today anything
that happens in the world we find out
about it within seconds due to social
media so the world's gotten bigger 8
billion but it's gotten smaller because
the impact has immediately felt all over
the world just because you have more
land doesn't mean you're stronger
military than another one that's got a
smaller land backed up by a bigger
government who am I talking about
Russia's got all the land in the world
Ukraine is this big but they're getting
support from NATO and U.S they are
standing against a country like Russia
which by the way we still don't know
what's going to happen going into 2023 a
lot of weird conversations are happening
but that's a David and Goliath story
going on so people are actually noticing
it matters to have a stronger military
and some people that you thought were
stronger are not really as strong as we
thought they were so very interesting
that happened between Russia and Ukraine
so those are 10 other lessons we learned
from 2022 and by the way I can add
another 10 more Bots if you want to be
prepared for the following year and you
want some hacks on how to properly write
a business plan I did a video on 12
building blocks that I used to drive you
both emotionally and logically if you've
not seen that highly recommend you watch
this video click here to watch the video
about the 12 building blocks take care
everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]